hello everyone and welcome to bloodline
the taxonomy of fear where we examine
what if anything makes a movie scary and
today we are at long last going to
examine torture porn which to be clear
is not porn the way food porn isn't
people having sex with food no not today
no not today today we examine torture
porn through the lens of the collection
the sequel to 2009's the collect or is
it movie Indecent movie indeed and in
this installment a young woman named
elena has been kidnapped by the
collector and trapped in his hell house
horrors and arkin our thief hero for his
first installment is enlisted with a few
mercenaries to go rescue her yep so here
we go alright so what defines torture
porn Jordan first of all big surprise
it's the torture the bulk of the
creative energy in these kinds of movies
is set towards how do people die where
do they die one of the pieces of them
looks like when they're like set apart
next to each other on a table those
sorts of things you know storyline could
be thin character could be thin but
whatever this is about devices and ways
of dying this movie had a little bit of
that but it wasn't like hostile or it
wasn't like it was odd that was there
was some torture but it wasn't
completely the whole thing torture can
be understated yes I think that's what
we're delivered here which I feel good
about yes number two revenge you're not
going to have to sit through all that
torture and not get the satisfying other
side of that equation torture porn
movies tend to have this where one of
the victims has an awesome and equally
horrific revenge on the perpetrator of
that torture yeah the end of the movie
saw even way back when to I Spit on Your
Grave there is supreme vindication with
these movies because you have earned it
after watching in this movie though you
will have had to have seen the first one
in order for the revenge of the second
one too
much more yeah this can be a standalone
but it definitely benefits from having
adapt to the first one for sure number
three the third element and my favorite
is the terrible place again all that
creative energy funneling into how to
kill people you need an environment in
which God family familiarity police
anything that could come to rescue you
or provide relief to your plight does
not exist abandon your company it tends
to be a very static place where the
weather bad guy can set up his gold
torture system and this dude in this
movie was like the Rube Goldberg of
torts of humanity he was there were
pulleys and there were levers and their
work lamps it was just also like
installation art in fact he did have
some had an art gallery yeah it was
covered so that's the linchpin the
terrible place and this has one yes
alright the insomnia factor J how many
hours of sleep did you forfeit after the
kind of none because torture porn in the
end is not really my thing torture
torture torture blood blood blood I
prefer more of it build up anything and
this was a good ride sort of a
satisfying movie I liked it and yeah I
like that Ryan mm-hmm nightmare Disney
like that's exactly and I didn't lose
any hours of sleep because the ending
was so vindicating so satisfying I was I
walked out of that theater ready to just
like throw a fist in the air and cheer
for pretty satisfied here of the
developments that happened yeah horror
movie survival lessons what did we learn
from the collection number one stay fit
like CrossFit philosophy speed agility
strength will get you out of a tight
squeeze like literally a tight squeeze
yeah and if you're in a tight enough
squeeze remember that sticks and stones
may break your bones but a snap arm may
be able to fit through a cage and open a
lock latch yes then finally number three
sometimes you just gotta shoot a
homeless person it kind of works i mean
the tactic worked it was terrible worked
yeah video pic of the week what into the
collection put you in my
for Jay I'm gonna recommend Takeshi me
TKS audition you will never look at
piano wire the same way again that's a
guarantee and I'm gonna say hostel part
2 if I thought was superior to part 1 I
got behind the story a little bit more
and I like to see some ladies kicking
ass that's a good yeah so that concludes
this segment of bloodline come back
check us out in a couple weeks and we'll
bring another installment of horror
goodness you email us at bloodline and
wired com we'd like to hear from you and
as we like to say here at bloodline
remember it's just a movie